a couple of years ago a couple of mostly
peaceful blm terrorists threw a molotov
cocktail into a cop car in new york
what made the incident even more
egregious than the other nationwide blm
violence that year
was that colin ford mattis and aruj
rahman were both attorneys
they were supposed to uphold the rule of
law and here they were tearing it down
and last week the injustice became even
more pronounced when these thugs
received a sweetheart plea deal
although mattis and rahman had been
facing terrorism charges and the
possibility of 30 years in prison
thanks to the biden administration's
intervention they will now likely see
only a couple years behind bars the deal
is even more puzzling to those who are
interested in seeing justice because
rahman and mattis
had already pled guilty last year to
possessing and making an explosive
device which would have put them in jail
for up to 10 years now this new deal
will allow them to withdraw their
previous plea and simply cop to the
lesser charges of conspiring to assemble
a molotov cocktail and damaging the cop
car
ramen at the very least has been
unrepentant
after the fact he said
the only way they hear us is through
violence and still he gets the deal the
other guy i suspect he's not repentant
either
still
let out on bail a bail paid
coincidentally by another attorney who
worked for the obama administration
meanwhile
meanwhile that's the guys on the left
the guys on the right right wingers who
made a mess of the capital rotunda on
january 6th january 6 the worst day ever
they are having the book thrown at them
they are wasting away in solitary
confinement is this slap on the wrist
for blm terrorism fair no is it just no
so why is it happening because
the liberal establishment wants more of
it it's simple as that the liberal
establishment benefits from blm violence
the way that it attracts money to
leftist causes the way that it
encourages liberal cultural
transformation the way it impels
conservatives to keep our mouths shut or
else or else we're gonna get some mostly
peaceful protests outside our house too
they like that they want more of that so
they let their thugs get away with it
what they don't want more of is
conservatives questioning their dubious
election schemes and so they discourage
that by destroying the lives of their
enemies on the flimsiest of charges
a lot of conservatives don't want to
believe that our politics has really
become this course this corrupt this
unprincipled this radical
but it has it has
two years ago the current vice president
of the united states raised money to
bail these criminals out of jail and get
them back on the streets
this is how the liberal ruling class
operates they play for keeps and if
you're surprised by this miscarriage of
justice
you just haven't been paying attention
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from the fable sphere
who says i think we have reached a point
whereby we can admit that michael does
in fact
like to say
i told you so you know i accept the
burden it's a burden it's it's a heavy
burden to be able to see the future
to be able to see to know
that when dr fauci tells you something
to know that in six to nine months it
won't it won't be proven true to know
that when leftist criminals get arrested
to know that they won't face any sort of
justice to know that when a conservative
is caught jaywalking the guy is going to
hang at dawn
they're going to throw the book at him
so severely it's it's a burden to do
that but i can't help it that's what we
do here on this show
and in a way it invigorates me to be
able to see what's going on a little bit
to tell you what the truth of the
political situation and it invigorates
me a little bit it gets my blood flowing
right it gets me feeling good just like
super beats her shoes right now go to
superbeats.com
knowles this is the new way to start
your day super beats heart shoes i love
them do you know why i love them
primarily because they're delicious
they're very very tasty and when super
beets heart shoes show up at the daily
wire all these jackals these hyenas
around here take them all before i can
get mine you don't need to worry the
second thing after how delicious they
are is also how good they'll make you
feel no more afternoon coffees no more
energy drinks no more candy for that
quick pick me up you just add two
delicious plant-based super beets heart
shoes to your morning routine and
promote heart-healthy energy for your
day without the caffeine crash super
beets heart chews unique clinically
researched grape seed extract promotes
heart-healthy energy and normal blood
pressure as part of a healthy lifestyle
i love them it tastes good it feels good
it's simpler than having to go up to the
coffee machine three times a day for our
listeners right now you can get up to 45
percent off plus free shipping at
superbeats.com knowles this is their
best offer available anywhere
superbeats.com knowles get up to 45 off
superbeats.com knowles these statements
and products have not been evaluated by
the food and drug administration these
products are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease or
condition
these guys play for keeps and we don't
get it we as conservatives
still believe
that we're operating in a political
context that that maybe existed 30 years
ago 40 years ago we think there's no way
that they're going to
they want to abolish the police there's
no way that they're going to they're
throwing molotov cocktails at the
buildings and not getting in trouble for
it there's no way that they're they're
transiting the kids there's no way
they're they're promoting fourth
trimester abortion what no there's no
but it just
keeps happening we say but that's
unprincipled it's immoral it's
contradictory to our christian
civilization to the constitution and
they'll say yep
uh-huh
yeah right we've been telling you for
decades we don't like the constitution
we don't like christian civilization we
don't like the traditional american
nation we hate it we don't like you guys
is what they've been telling us for
decades and we just don't believe it
we we hope against hope that that that's
not really true but it is there's a
democratic rep representative mandera
jones
who just came out he's very upset
because the democrats can't ram through
gun control and they can't ram through
gun control because
most people don't really want gun
control they might tell a pollster that
well we need to do something about guns
but when it comes down to actually
taking away people's gun rights the
people don't really want it this is why
the elected representatives of the
people can't get it through this is why
democrats are going to have a very hard
time running on this in the midterms and
so
monday jones he says look if the rules
of our government of our representative
democracy
won't allow us to get rid of guns
well screw them we'll we'll get rid of
the rules
we did not choose this fight
we had our own dreams for our lives the
same as you did when you were kids but
we can't let you get away with this
anymore
enough is enough enough of you telling
us that school shootings are a fact of
life when every other country like ours
has virtually ended it
enough of you blaming mental illness and
then defunding mental health care in
this country
enough of your thoughts and prayers
enough
enough
you will not stop us from advancing the
protecting our kids act today
you will not stop us from passing it in
the house next week and you will not
stop us there
if the filibuster obstructs us
we will abolish it
if the supreme court objects we will
expand it and we will not rest until we
have taken weapons of war out of
circulation in our communities
each and every day we will do whatever
it takes to end gun violence whatever it
takes
we will do whatever it takes
that's what the left has been telling us
for a long time and we just don't
believe that
no you wouldn't abolish the filibuster
you know they the democrats have
abolished the filibuster for quite a lot
of the operation of the senate they
haven't totally obliterated it yet
though they theoretically could
they you wouldn't really expand the
supreme court you wouldn't upend the
balance of power in this country upend
our system of government yes we will is
what they're saying
but the second amendment to constitute
we don't like the constitution
but the american tradition we all like
the american tradition
but our our balanced system of checks
and balances and separation of power we
don't like separation of power we don't
like checks and balances they don't
they've been telling us this and they're
willing to get rid of all of it and we
need to accept that that is what they're
after you don't believe
you don't believe monday or jones well
representative david sicilian another
democrat where they were just debating
some more new gun legislation and they
brought up the fact that there are
constitutional rights here that protect
people
people's ability to keep and bear arms
and david sicily and said oh your
constitutional rights i'll tell you
exactly where you can put your
constitutional rights
spare me the [ __ ] about
constitutional rights
no i will not yield and i'm not going to
yield for my entire five minutes so
don't ask again that could be the
democrats campaign slogan spare me the
bs about constitutional rights
absolutely it could
100
that could be the democrats campaign
slogan now what democrats could say is
they'll say well listen you republi we
we're defending the constitutional
rights to abortion and you oppose that
constitutional right we're you know the
democrats have made up a lot of
constitutional rights in the last 50
years
that are probably actually going to be
overruled in the next week or so
possibly the next day
but
when you when you listen to the
arguments that both sides are making
about the country
that's where you can tell that this
isn't just a game of you hate the
constitution no you hate the
constitution no you ate the constitution
because it's true republicans do not i
some republicans do i guess
conservatives certainly don't believe
that there is any constitutional right
to an abortion no one thought that there
was any constitutional right to an
abortion until the 1970s and then they
upheld it in the 90s but they said that
the reasoning for why they had it in the
70s was bs and that so no one no one
ever thought that and the conservatives
have said we support the constitution
the left when it's convenient for them
will pretend that their radical desires
are in the constitution but then they'll
also embrace the 1619 project
then they'll also
say whatever means necessary then
they'll also say who cares about your bs
constitutional rights they'll also say
it's all terrible we want to upend the
constitution when they're being really
honest that's what they tell you
that is the mainstream
of the democratic party right now those
are elected representatives at the
national level
who are saying that chuck schumer for
goodness sakes when the supreme court
was going to hand down a ruling he
didn't like he goes outside the supreme
court he says you better watch out we're
coming for you we're coming for you
kavanagh we're coming for you
making threats to another branch of the
government that's the mainstream
so that's what they want
the
radical all the way up to the mainstream
of the democrat party says
screw your constitutional rights we're
going to take away your guns we're going
to take away your
rights of self-government we're going to
take away your right to articulate to
the filibuster we're going to take away
your right to deliberative
representatives okay what what do our
radicals say are radicals to the
mainstream what are they defending
they're defending
the american nation the really basic
stuff hot dogs on the 4th of july and
the star-spangled banner now when you
want really good meat whether it's on
the 4th of july or wherever you've got
to check out good ranchers right now go
to goodranchers.com
knowles go there right now good ranchers
is so good that not only is it the meat
that i have sweet little elisa cook up
for me all the time they're delicious
steaks they're delicious burgers they're
delicious chicken
but even i am not i am not much of a
cook these days i don't i don't usually
if elise is out of town i'll just do
takeout until i remembered i had that
good ranchers in my freezer and i said
i'm not doing takeout throw some of
their delicious better than organic
chicken on the grill two seconds it's
delicious juicy they got the beef they
got the chicken they got the seafood
they've got an incredible deal right now
you can you can get a great deal on the
meat you can get a great deal on
subscribing for your meat and you get
two free ribeyes that's a hundred dollar
value when you go check out good
ranchers today you go to
goodranchers.com knowles use code
knowles get two 18 ounce prime center
cut rib eyes for free with your order
with father's day around the corner this
is the perfect time to try a box of good
ranchers what better way to show your
appreciation for dad than with a box of
100 delicious american meat good
ranchers delivers what you want when you
need it you make that one time purchase
or subscribe and save 25 on every box
they're giving away two free revise with
your order limited time offer do not
miss it other places will charge you
over 50 bucks per stake for rib eyes
like these good ranchers is giving two
of them away for free usda prime 100
american steakhouse quality cuts of beef
they are out of their ranching mines go
to goodranchers.com knowles claim your
rib eyes today before they run out start
the summer off right with good ranchers
american meat delivered
well the democrats are saying all the
way up to very prominent elected office
they're saying we need to take away your
guns we need to trans your kids we need
to kill your babies we hate the american
flag we've got to hoist the pride flag
everywhere around the country in
kindergarten classrooms all the way over
to the vatican
that's the kind of stuff they're pushing
what are our radicals saying marjorie
taylor green
oh that radical oh she's so crazy oh my
goodness she's always trending on
twitter the democrats hate her so much
what are some of the crazy things that
they're really upset
at her for saying
the really the craziest wildest thing
they're upset with her for saying is
that she defends
the american nation and christianity
you see
nationalism is a good thing it's where
all americans should be we should be
wanting america first we should be
wanting our tax dollars our focus our
legislation our bills and our leadership
focused on our nation we should be proud
of nationalism and we should be proud of
an america first nationalism and then
lastly
we should be most proud of christianity
so if christian nationalism is something
to be scared of they're lying to you and
they're lying to you on purpose because
that is exactly the temperature change
that is happening in america today and
they can't control it they can't control
it and that's what terrifies them the
most
she is 100 right here this is why the
libs are making such a big boogie man
out of christian nationalism that's the
new phrase du jour
they're doing that because that is the
opposite of the form of government that
they want
which is liberal imperialism
they believe that america is nothing
more than a system of values
and it coincidentally happens to be
whatever values they want at any given
moment transgendering the kids yes
that's at the very heart of america oh
yes washington and hamilton they fought
the revolution so that we could pump
kids full of puberty blockers it's an
abstract right america is nothing but an
idea they they push for that on the one
hand liberalism
and then
they push for imperialism as the form of
the government
they don't want to just confine that to
america's borders they want to spread it
all around the world
this is why the libs prefer the pride
flag to the red white and blue flag the
red white and blue stars and stripes
american flag is the flag of a nation
the rainbow flag is the flag of an
empire the star stars and stripes
that's the flag of borders of people of
tradition of a way of life
that has existed in a particular place
for centuries
the pride flag is just about the idea of
do whatever you want the pride flag
means exactly what it means whether you
wave it in america or whether you wave
it in tibet it's always making the same
claims it doesn't make claims about a
particular people in a particular region
with a particular shared history it's
for everybody man do do what you want to
do that's why that's also why the pride
flag is always changing that's why they
keep adding colors every four hours i
think at this point they add new colors
because it's just an idea that's
expanding and growing man
that's that's imperial
i do not have any particular preference
for nationalism or imperialism i think
there have been good countries in bad
countries good nations and good nations
good empires and bad empires
but right now
the
the
libs are pushing
liberal
empire
an empire that spreads all around the
world through the non-profits and the
corporations sometimes military invasion
to defend american values by which they
just mean the rainbow flag and i oppose
that i think that's a bad idea i don't
think that we should be
spreading our resources all around the
world whether we're talking about blood
treasure any of that any of that to
promote
liberalism i don't think that's a good
idea i don't i don't think that's a good
use of any of our resources so the if
the alternative to global empire
to to liberal empire is nationalism then
i guess i'm for nationalism and the
alternative here obviously to liberalism
is christianity something is going to
animate your country
some spirit is going to animate your
country it's going to form the culture
for the vast majority of american
history that was christianity you see it
in our earliest documents all the way up
until very very recently and there have
been prayers and there have been
speeches of thanksgiving the most famous
speeches in american history invoke god
because they have to because not only is
politics downstream of culture the
culture is downstream of religion
everyone forgets that second part all
human conflict ultimately is theological
and so you're gonna have ideas about
what is
good and bad and right and wrong and
true and false and those are religious
ideas so are you going to have the
religion of liberalism the religion of
leftism the religion of progressivism or
christianity what do you want to animate
your culture i bet
for normal people out there even the
ones who aren't christian the ones who
are jews the ones who are muslims the
one who are just sort of atheists and
agnostics but they have a nostalgia for
america for the america that we all grew
up in and knew and know and love
i think they would rather live in a
christian culture do you want to live in
a culture that's known for its
cathedrals and beautiful works of art
and people generally behaving themselves
or do you want to live in in the culture
of liberalism where where kids are being
dragged to drag shows where
pride flags are hanging everywhere where
we're killing babies left and right
where we're tearing down statues of our
forebears where we're completely
rewriting history and censoring
literature and getting rid of all of the
beautiful culture that we've become
accustomed to that we we unfortunately
no longer seem to appreciate in this
country which co which one do you want
to live in it's obviously
obviously the former speaking of those
drag shows
or pal flekas talks one of his
journalists
just
caught
one of the most disturbing things i've
seen
in
a few weeks you want to know what the
liberal empire is selling they go to
this dallas gay bar
and they go to an event drag the kids to
pride
drag the kids to pride that doesn't
sound great
it's a show at
mr mr barr
billed as a family-friendly version of
the bar's regular champagne drag
lunch here's what they saw
how do you think the event went today
i think it was amazing i never get to
like perform in front of children like
performing in front of children i have
like six other younger siblings so it
was it was very emotional i loved it it
was probably one of the best shows i've
ever done what do you say to the
conservative parents that wouldn't bring
their children to an event like this
why here's the thing i don't think that
there is any kind of issue with exposing
children to this because
especially
if you if your child is in the community
or you may think they are i just think
that drag is educational do you think
that exposing uh children to drag will
lead children to do drag in the future
in the long run
not if they don't want to do drag i'm a
gay man and i don't want to do drag
so i don't think no absolutely not if
not grooming is not
you will be what you're what you are
we're not going to turn you into
something else because you come and see
this event
this video is so enlightening one
obviously this is freakish and perverse
and horrible and under no circumstances
should
should drag queens be allowed to jiggle
for kids you heard how creepy that guy
was at the top because i never get to to
dance around for kids this is really
great i love dancing around for kids in
my high heels and my this guy should be
arrested for doing this so
you know the video serves that purpose
too but it's so
telling about the
about the
hidden agenda here the not-so-hidden
agenda here because
the the little group at the end of the
of the people wearing the beto shirts
who just were customers at this bar who
are just talking about the show they
give one answer
to the question of what this means for
kids but the drag queen gives a totally
different answer
you saw they was asked so you really
think kids should be at this thing and
the drag queen he says
oh yeah i think drag is educational
and then
the the people in the beto shirts at the
end they say you really think kids
should be at this thing they say oh yeah
it's no big deal they're not being
indoctrinated they're not being educated
no it's there and yet that guy he says
no look it's not going to make kids more
inclined to do drag
no look i'm a gay guy and i don't want
to do drag and so kids are going to be
what they're going to be kids are going
to be who they are that woman there she
says no kids are they are what they are
and they never
change at all well those are totally
contradictory views of education of
human nature of the mind of the soul
the drag queen is saying you become
something
you you start out one way but then
through education you become something
else education shapes your desires
education shapes your interests
education shapes your beliefs
and then the the
ridiculous group of people at the end in
the beta shirt they say nah education
doesn't do any of that you're just born
a certain way and you never change at
all ever you don't change your beliefs
you don't change your desires you don't
change your interests you don't change
anything you just nothing affects you
who's right
obviously the drag queen is right here
obviously
not just drag shows are educational but
all of culture is educational and all of
these lessons and all of these
instructions if if they weren't we
wouldn't send kids to school if we
weren't we wouldn't learn anything if if
they weren't educational if they if they
weren't another way of saying that is
indoctrinating if they weren't
formative in shaping people's views
especially little kids whose brains are
so malleable if they weren't
accomplishing that
in the drag shows then the left wouldn't
be promoting them
now when you've got a culture that is
just so crazy
and and everything seems to be
up in the air
you've got to protect yourself with some
tangible assets that's why you got to
check out birch gold right now text
nulls 298 98 98 whatever you're doing i
don't care stop text knolls to 98 98 98
out of control inflation is hammering
the stock market because everyone is so
afraid of what this is going to mean for
their wealth the s p 500 is having the
worst start to the year since world war
ii
right now is a good time
for you to consider diversifying into
gold the most stable asset in the
history of the world birch gold is the
company i trust to help you convert an
ira or 401k
into an ira in gold and silver not only
will birchgold help you fortify your
savings with precious metals they'll
will help you do it in a tax sheltered
account text knowles canadawlis to
9898.98 to get started amazon's stock is
down 37 percent in the first half of the
year tesla's down 40
cryptos have been slammed many fear that
the hawkish moves by the fed could stall
out the economy so what's your plan
right now text knowledge to 98 98 98 the
best time to do it was yesterday the
second best time is today get your free
no obligation info kit on gold from
birch gold these guys are the precious
metals professionals text novels 98 98
98 secure your savings now
the other thing you got to check out
is the documentary that everyone in
america is talking about you know what
i'm saying what is a woman
what is a woman is so
so good
i had high expectations for it initially
it has exceeded my expectations matt is
just a stone cold psychopath he's
interviewing these radicals and he just
keeps a straight face the whole time and
he allows them to hoist themselves on
their own petard i know that sounds kind
of dirty but and i guess in this case it
is pretty dirty but it's
metaphorically they do the same thing
you must you must be a member to watch
the movie so right now you can become a
member at daily wire get 25 off your new
membership at whatisawoman.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
the reason that the libs are pushing for
younger and younger people and younger
and younger kids to go to pride parades
to go to drag shows to go to gay bars to
watch men jiggle around the reason
they're pushing for this is because it
is formative is because it shapes their
minds
they are telling us this they are
telling us this in their own words and
so they cannot well they can but they it
won't make any sense and it's obviously
disingenuous they cannot simultaneously
tell us that the drag shows are not
doing any of that that the pride parades
are not doing any of that
we have to we have to we're not
indoctrinating the kids in
radical sexual ideologies and it's good
that we are that's the argument they're
making the washington post is trying to
make sense of this they it was one of
the funniest articles i have read in a
mainstream paper in a very very long
time headline
gender identity lessons banned in some
schools are rising in others
and here is the the real money line
here's the
thesis of the of the column or of the
news article rather in florida and
several other states educators are
restricted in teaching about gender
identity but elsewhere teachers are
embracing the topic as the number of
transgender and gender non-binary
children rises
and i
i love this line because you might not
catch it if you're just reading it
quickly okay dude all right there's
different schools or disagreeing on you
but i love the way they frame it here in
florida and certain other states the the
conservatives are tamping down on
transiting the kids
but in other schools teachers are
embracing this topic
as the number of children who are
getting trans rises
you think those two things might have
something to do with one another it's
just so strange
it's i can't can you believe these
conservatives they don't want to
we the number of transgender children is
rising so why don't they want to teach
lessons where they encourage kids to
become transgender it's so weird
maybe because maybe because the lessons
are impelling people to become
transgender it reminds me of this of
this article by fox butterfield in the
new york times this is a famous headline
in the new york times they say
despite drop in crime
an increase in inmates
despite
crime falling the prisons keep filling
despite i don't know that despite means
what you think it means actually maybe
there's a connection here it's a
strange social phenomenon
that the crime rate continues to fall
even though we keep putting all the
criminals in prison like isn't that so
weird no it's it it's only weird it's
only difficult to understand if you are
so taken with a radical ideology that
you can't see
plain realities right before your very
eyes
i'm so glad that the washington post
i'm so glad that that drag queen at that
bar in dallas i'm so glad that some of
the libs at least
are beginning to admit
that we were right all along arby you
know how much i hate to say i told you
so
you know how much i hate to take out my
nostradamus had my crystal ball and
predict the future
but they're telling us we were right
they're saying yeah we are grooming them
at the very least we're grooming them
intellectually at the very least we're
grooming them in their moral sense to
become accustomed to drag shows to i
mean at this show you had little kids
putting dollar bills in the thongs of
these creeps
this is
overtly explicitly sexual stuff they say
yeah no but it's all fun it's just to
teach tolerance maybe we shouldn't
tolerate that or we're going to tolerate
everything no
the libs certainly don't tolerate
everything they in fact
as we all know i almost don't even want
to say it's become cliche at this point
they're extremely intolerant of all the
normal good traditional stuff that we've
ever had in this country they're
intolerant of the american flag in some
cases they protest the star-spangled
banner so it's not a question of being
more tolerant or being less tolerant
moreover though sometimes you'll hear
conservatives say we're the really
tolerant ones we're the real liberals
i'm a conservative because i'm a liberal
because i'm so tolerant i think you
should be able to say and do whatever
you want no that's not true either we
are also not the totally tolerant ones
nobody is totally tolerant nobody really
believes that people should be able to
say and do whatever they want whenever
they want to do it no that isn't true at
least i don't
i don't i don't want to tolerate the
drag show for kids i think that should
be shut down and the people who i think
there should be a law passed against it
and when people break that law i think
they should go to prison for a very long
time
call me intolerant
i call me
michael you're just not open-minded
enough i guess i'm not some people it
seems are so open-minded that their
brains have fallen out
no we we don't we're we're not totally
open and totally liberal and totally no
every culture has standards actually i
think today the that wow providential
the paperback of my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is the number one national
best-selling book came out last year uh
the paperback is out today so you can
get that wherever you get fine books
about how we shouldn't tolerate
everything certainly not drag queens
trying to trans the kids do not do that
the sexual ideology that the libs are
promoting
ultimately is incoherent and you can see
this
you can see this especially
in a story from the new york post just
came out a few days ago
i'm in a relationship with my 1998 chevy
and our sex life is so special that is
the headline of it i think do we have
some b-roll of this
relationship yeah so it's
this is sort of i almost feel bad even
playing this it's a guy just kissing his
car and
and lying underneath his car and doing
all sorts of creepy things with his car
says uh he's 37 years old
he he came out
about 10 years ago as being in love with
his car
and all right that's enough beer i don't
need to see him kiss his car anymore
that's fine that's i'm sorry i asked i'm
sorry i asked it was my fault but i'm
sorry i asked he was on this show tlc's
my strange addiction
and it went viral at the time and now 10
years later he says i'm still i'm still
in love with my car i got a feel for my
automobile i like to lean over his
fender and across his hood and kind of
press up against him okay you get the
idea and he says that he does all the
sorts of things with this car
that
married people do with one another
the sexual revolutionaries are going to
laugh at this
they're going to say oh come on this is
what how dare you are you you're you're
comparing all of our kind of bizarre
sexual eccentricities like drag shows
for kids you're comparing it to this
wacko guy
who's got
objectophilia is the apparently the
medical term for it and he's in in love
with his car it's completely
incomparable
sure sure now when when we conservatives
have been accused of suggesting a
slippery slope in years past
it's taken about what
uh six months to at most five or six
years before we are at that point on the
slippery slope we get we get to that
slippery slope pretty pretty quickly but
actually the the guy in love with his
car poses a much bigger
question for the sexual revolutionaries
than say
people warning about pedophilia remember
during the sexual revolution there were
conservatives who are warning you know
if you normalize
certain errant and deviant sexual
behaviors pretty soon people are going
to try to normalize pedophilia and the
lib said that's not true that's
ridiculous that'll never happen and what
are they doing they're obviously
normalizing pedophilia right now you can
see it on tape and you can hear them
make the arguments there was that
professor who was fired from uh from
old dominion college
for trying to normalize pedophilia and
then the the professor just got hired by
johns hopkins i believe
by a technically even more prestigious
university so they are normalizing this
but they'll say well look they might uh
if we normalize
deviant sexual behaviors
pretty soon some people will be trying
to normalize uh bestiality
that's true that's been less common than
the people trying to normalize pedos but
you have seen pockets of that
but this is an even bigger this actually
is a bigger problem because
the sexual revolutionaries can say look
we support
the whole acronym and having you know
giant monkey pox orgies and you know
throuples and quadruples and quintuples
and all they can say we support all that
stuff because it's all consensual
consent is the key here and a child
cannot consent now the libs are
weakening on this already
they're saying no a child not only can a
child consent to sex but a child can
consent to
making permanent sexual decisions like
lopping off parts of his body so they're
already weakening on that but in theory
they could make that argument or they
could say look an animal cannot consent
this is why it's wrong to
to sleep with animals is if you you know
that you're violating their consent and
that's wrong but then my question is
what about the chevy
what about the 1998 chevy the 1998 chevy
doesn't have will doesn't have freedom
of choice is not a conscious being to my
knowledge it's just an old car
so if this guy wants to do all sorts of
creepy things and say love his love and
respect our love with his car
what's wrong with that
we all know
that this is extremely disordered and
wrong and should be discouraged and this
guy should seek help and not be
celebrated for
doing these sorts of things with his car
we all know that
but why
why conservatives can answer why
christians jews muslims people with a
traditional even somewhat traditional
religious sentence and moral sense can
tell you why because they'll say well
that
buddy
that body part of yours is not meant for
that muffler that that's not actually
men and women are complimentary and they
go together and they get married and
they create children and it's wrong and
you shouldn't do that thing that you're
doing underneath the car and that's just
intrinsically wrong and it's disordered
and it's contrary to the natural law
and they we can explain why it's wrong
but if your only
criterion for sexual ethics is
if is consent
consent and if it feels good do it then
you can't say this is wrong and i bet
you if you talk to the real the real
radicals out there on the sexual
revolutionary side you said hey what do
you think about the guy who's in a
relationship with his 98 chevy they
would say well you know if he likes it
whatever it's not hurting anybody who
cares it's fine let him do it that's
okay yeah that's not my thing but that's
fine
that is
that is a real divide
i
don't think that we as a society
should encourage that i don't think that
the guy this guy has any right to
do those sorts of things with his car
i don't think that this is some sacred
natural i don't think love is love i
don't think
i don't think that
the the guy's relationship with his car
is something admirable that we should
encourage
and so
if we're if we're now at that position
where we're saying actually
some things are wrong then then and only
then can we crawl back to the like hey
maybe the kids should not be at the drag
show putting dollar bills in the g
strings of these weirdos
then and only then can we get back to
hey maybe you shouldn't be pumping
seven-year-olds full of puberty blockers
and cross-sex hormones potentially
then and only then can we get back to
some semblance of hey hey maybe marriage
has a meaning
when we say marriage has a meaning by
the way we're not saying that we need we
should be really cruel to people who
have different sexual desires we should
be we should just beat these guys up we
should oppress them we should run them
out no one's saying that
we're saying that there is reality
that there is such a thing as marriage
and marriage has a meaning
no matter what the radicals want to
pretend the meaning is i can i can say
that this
leftist tears tumbler is a chainsaw and
i can even force everyone around me to
call it a chainsaw but it's not a
chainsaw because their reality has some
say here it's a leftist tears tumbler
and the point of it is to drink
delicious leftist tears there's a new
poll that just came out
came out from gallup founding that
most americans support the redefinition
of marriage that the supreme court did
in the obergefell case
they support legal same-sex marriage
this is at an all-time high 71
back in 1996 only 27 percent of the
public
supported redefining marriage
americans who rarely or never go to
church have been the most supportive of
same-sex marriage
from the very beginning
on the on the other hand 58 of americans
who report that they attend church
weekly
oppose same-sex marriage well 40 of that
group are in favor so that's actually a
pretty scary statistic even for the
christians
christianity is pretty clear about what
marriage is it's one it's one of the
few
what you would call political issues
that christ talks about explicitly and
defines explicitly actually even in in
opposition to some of the prevailing
divorce practices of the time
he's very clear about this and yet forty
percent of people who say i'm a
christian i go to i go to church every
week even they support this radical
redefinition but the majority don't why
this is not surprising of course
the the last hold out group on
redefining marriage is
regular practicing christians because
they are at least more likely to know
what they believe they have a view of
things and the left wants to say it's
animated by hatred or bigotry or
closed-mindedness it's not
it's not motivated by any it's just
it's motivated by a view of the way that
things actually are
that coincidentally is the view that
every human being ever in the whole
history of the world until five minutes
ago believed
so there but
if you're if you're still going to
church every week
that means that you're at least more
likely to oppose
the left i mean don't forget even the
term the left
came up during the french revolution to
describe the people who opposed the
church to to describe the people who are
trying to upend the church and upend
christianity and recreate the world anew
out of their own unfettered reason
nothing has really changed all that much
at least about the logic of these
political movements during that time is
it any wonder that the libs are doing
everything they can to stop people from
reading the bible in schools to stop
people from praying in schools to go
after churches to shut down the churches
during coronavirus even while they keep
the pot dispensaries open to try to take
away the tax exempt status of the
churches to try to pressure pastors to
change their views to be in accord with
political correctness to try to
anathematize christians is it any wonder
of course they are doing that that is
the stumbling block that is the
impediment to their radical political
agenda and they will do whatever it
takes to implement that
speaking of weird sex stuff this story
came out last week i didn't have time to
get to it but i really don't want to let
it go michael avenatti the former future
democrat president michael avenatti the
man who was going to take down trump and
go on tv seven bazillion times
and was actually being fed as a
presidential candidate
he was just sentenced to four years in
prison for uh robbing a porn star
for stealing money from his client
stormy daniels
uh avenatti was representing daniels
and he stole nearly three hundred
thousand dollars from her
after the release of her biography
full disclosure
he's just uh he's just a dirtbag lawyer
right
that's i don't know how to say it in any
more charitable way he is a sleazy
dirtbag lawyer who uses prostitutes to
try to score political points and
advance his own career and then he takes
money from them too and then he tries to
extort big corporations and and throw
his
cheap political influence around and
he's just
anyone could see it from a mile away you
don't need your nostradamus hat to be
able to tell from the beginning this guy
is bad news this guy should have no
voice in the american public so of
course the libs breathlessly promoted
him
michael avenatti is laying down the law
and is he really thinking about running
for president
joining me now live the man himself
michael avenatti let's talk to somebody
who understands the system very well
michael avenatti he's donald trump's
worst nightmare michael
michael thanks so much for being here
did you talk to stormy daniels last
night what was her reaction did the
president just get a new challenger for
2020. stormy daniels lawyer michael
avenatti may have just tossed his hat
into the ring looking ahead to 2020
one reason why i'm taking you seriously
as a contender is because of your
presence on cable news first let me take
a moment to brag on my former student
this dude right here i think of him as
in a justice league with robert mueller
to save our democracy he's going to save
our democracy right after he gets out of
the clink for robbing a porn star his
client a porn star
michael avenatti made
121 appearances on cnn alone just and he
was on all the other channels too
but cnn alone they had him
121 times
in a very short period of time
he's donald trump's worst nightmare he's
gonna democrats just got a new candidate
baby
oh he's a fraud shakedown artist okay
never mind go away no we don't need to
answer for him anymore every one of
those cable news guys every one of those
democrat operatives should answer for
michael avenatti
the next time that they start
pontificating
about our democracy and integrity and
character character matters oh yeah
well how's your judgment of character
libs how's your how's your judgment of
character cnn you you promoted this guy
who is cartoonishly
sleazy
and criminal
how is your oh never mind
because being being
a democrat being a liberal in our
society means never having to say that
you're sorry they just move right on
it's like that old clinton strategy deny
deny deny deny deny okay it's old news
moving right along
so michael avenatti going to michael
avenatti at the very least will be held
somewhat accountable for stealing that
money speaking of fiscal fiscal
accountability elon musk just criticized
the biden administration for completely
botching the economy and joe biden was
asked about elon's criticism and job i
think the question even was planted
frankly joe biden thought he had such a
great zinger against elon musk but the
zinger didn't quite work
elon musk has asked has said that he has
a super bad feeling about the u.s
economy he's laying off 10 of his
workforce what do you say to elon musk
about his feeling about the economy
jamie dimon has said some one thing
well let me tell you while eon musk is
talking about that ford is increasing
their investment overwhelmingly i think
ford is increasing the investment in
building new electric vehicles 6 000
new employees union employees i might
add in the midwest
um the
former chrysler corporation stellantas
they are also making similar investments
and electric vehicles
intel is about 20 000 new jobs for
making computer chips um so uh you know
lots of luck in his trip to the moon i
mean i i don't i mean
yeah boom owned roasted elon lots of
luck on your trip to the moon
you know that this was a planted
question because biden right away pulled
out his little cheat sheet
of bullet points where he thought this
is going to be a great way to dunk on
elon we know that that the white house
plans questions all the time because
biden actually tells us i'm supposed to
call on johnny next what was that thing
that you're gonna so he pulls it out and
good luck on your trip to the moon elon
the only problem with that zinger
is that it turns out
that the
federal government is funding elon's
trip to the moon nasa chose elon to
partner with to go to the moon elon is
actually responsible for helping the
american space program and the american
space program is paying for it probably
should have googled it how are who is
running the white house obviously not
joe biden but how how does this even you
think i've got this great dunk here and
then he just dunks completely
on himself unless he maybe he was
sincere good luck good luck elon say i
hope it's good luck because we're paying
for it
federal government before we go i have
to get to this one line too speaking of
language flops a chunk jugger is the guy
from the young turks
and he's belligerent and extremely
left-wing and usually very disrespectful
so
chen yuger just tweeted out the other
day he said do republicans speak english
what part of well-regulated means no
regulations
he's talking about the first amendment
right which says or the second amendment
rather which says a well-regulated
militia being necessary to the security
of a free state the right of the people
to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
and we
without debating the constitutional
history of gun laws and gun control
without debating what the militia
what role the militia played in the
founding of the country and what it what
role it plays today
i just have to point out that the
incoherence
that chunky is accusing the republicans
of demonstrating he himself is
demonstrating just on
the english language just on exactly
what he's talking about
the phrase a well-regulated militia
being necessary to the security of a
free state
is a parenthetical phrase it's not it's
not the main clause of the sentence
again i'm i'm not professing to be a
constitutional scholar or a a gun expert
or i'm just but i do know the basic
rules of the english language
the the main clause the independent
clause here is the right of the people
to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed
i could say michael knowles michael
knowles's hair looking really really uh
swarthy looking really really suave and
oily and poofy today the right of the
people to keep and bear arms shall not
be infringed
and what still
that parenthetical would be
parenthetical that the main clause does
not hinge on that parenthetical clause
so he's saying it's true it is true it
tells you something about what gun
rights mean in america that
we need a well-regulated militia that we
need to be able to defend ourselves to
protect ourselves that's how you keep a
state free
but he's saying all of that is just
preface to say the right of the people
to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed if the libs want to get rid of
gun rights and the second amendment
they've got to deal with the main clause
they can't just deal with the
parenthetical clause maybe they probably
chen huger doesn't know that but the
smart liberals do know that and they're
just ignoring it and they're just
neglecting it because they will push
their agenda by any means necessary
because they play
to win maybe we should recognize that
maybe maybe we should up our game a
little bit too i'm michael knowles the
michael noel show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2022. on the matt wall show
we talk about the things that matter
real issues that affect you your family
our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show